hey guys and welcome to glorious 480 p
roller coast i can three yeah i have a
couple of things to explain right here
so i was going to record an episode of
my let's play just got it all hooked up
and everything just was completely ready
to destroy this game and make the most
beautiful things and I was recording
with fraps as you can see in the top
right corner right there and recorded
all that and it took me like over two
hours and for some reason I then removed
the video file it wasn't exactly after
that but at some point I figured mm my
entire HDD is just completely full of
[ __ ] and I need to get rid of all bats
so at that point I deleted that all the
videos that were over there which most
of most of which were used for videos
already but it turns out that i also
took the recording for this video so i'm
extremely sorry that this video is in
terrible quality tim 480p it should be
even though it says 720 that's because i
render sony vegas in 720 i don't even
really care at this point but yeah the
quality really isn't that good so yeah
if you really just feel like yeah that's
too bad of quality i don't want to go to
youtube 2008 so you can always just kind
of skip this episode i suppose i just
wanted to get this out there because i
still had this streamed i had this this
thing i stream this all the way through
and I had that stream archived on my
twitch and just went so amateur and just
just uploaded that onto YouTube made it
private used a MP mp4 converter make the
video unlisted of course because you
can't convert private videos and that
was also an issue and got that onto my
computer but now is not very HD or
anything so it's banned in that respect
but it's also like I had to cook I had
to edit out a couple of times when I got
out of roller coaster Guthrie to go like
to the song requests or something like
that or try to look at OBS for my
settings and it's really not all that
good but then again I have still
recorded this episode and I haven't even
talked about what I was doing in this
episode I suppose that's also a good
thing to talk about really there isn't
that much going on here just
some basic path works and things really
I think the only really valuable thing
that I have done was placed this flat
ride which was just kind of yeah it's
all right in the end honestly not not
too much over here I just kind of needed
this to fill up the space but also to
have more flat rides in the park which
is something that you know I am kind of
struggling with since this is obviously
not going to be a standards type of
theme park in a sense that for example
Busch Gardens would be standard but also
like some of these smaller parks where
you just really have many paths and flat
rides everywhere since I can't do
something like that for a couple of
reasons obviously that's the fact that
there just aren't into flat rides to
fill this entire Park up with that rides
there's also the fact that I want to
focus on scenery and theming and not
break that too much and there aren't
really too many flat rides that you know
I in a way built to a certain theme like
I can get the magic carpet for the
Arabian area but there's not much more
and there's only a couple of generic
flat rides that you can fill in an area
before the area starts getting generic
and of course i also want to focus on
the dark rides / shops / roller coasters
roller coasters are much better to scene
than flat rides are so i might actually
want to kind of focus on that and just
kind of keep the flat rides out there to
make their park look realistic have
something for the kids as well because
you kind of want to mix that up you
don't want to have like all the kids
stuff in one corner of the park and all
the roller coasters in the other corner
at least that's not something that i
think is a great thing to do and yeah
there just comes to mix it up and make
sure that i do have that in the park but
they're not really my focus point so if
any of my flat rides start ending up
like complete and utter turds that's the
reason for that happening though I must
say if any flat ride is going to look
like a terd I'm gonna have to get rid of
that also that was just me opening
notepad for my tutorial list which you
just called a glimpse of him which is
actually still quite large and which I
do also need to start working on damn it
and I've just been kind of busy with
things
but yeah I need to start working on that
soon too in any case this flat right
right here is just a simple little boat
thing I figured if I get the boats in
anywhere it's got to be the
Mediterranean area I don't think there's
any other place where they would fit as
well really since you know I can have a
cup of palm trees and palm trees and
pirate ships are always cool I suppose I
don't really see the link too much but
in any case I just felt like this was
the only thing that I could really get
in there which would kind of fit it and
which I wouldn't be able to fit in as
well in other areas also it's pretty
small and just easy to get in there now
as you can clearly see Q lines is
something that I really just need to put
some more effort into and also kind of
me to look at since this Q line really
isn't that amazing and I do kind of need
to look at how I can actually make them
look good like that's one of the that's
one of the only things that I'm worried
about really I know that I complain
every so often about things that don't
work and there was again just trying to
look up music but in any case I know
that I always complain about things that
I feel like they don't look good or
something like that which is not
something that I want to do really but
sometimes I just can't not do it but I
feel pretty confident about the fact
that i can get facades done in this park
that i can get the path work done in a
way that I like that I can get the
fitting foliage but flat rides are
really and queues or religious something
that I'm unsure about when it comes to
this bike also for some areas i still
need to like get some good custom secret
or just try other custom scenery sad to
see if there's anything that I can do
with that that might also become a
problem like when's the last time that
you actually found a Dutch custom Sydney
said other than CT our sins or a
typically English custom scenery said
I'm not gonna completely be able to do
that in a way that I like it with just
some mock tudor all over the place so
those are definitely things that I need
to think about as well in other case I'm
really drifting off again I should be
talking about the palace just decided to
keep do close this door in the end not
really use that for anything I mean it
would have been so amazing to use that
thing
for the Q just have that cue enter at
the front of the building of the queue
line go in front of the building as well
but the issue with that really is how
are you going to get back to the normal
parts in a way that is actually that
actually looks all right and doesn't
completely ruin the area and that's
something that I was too worried about
to actually try it out like that so in
the end just kind of figured to get a
door in here I think I got a door in
here though I might not have and also
get a small Boulevard in front of this
building so i can actually have some
planters and trees because that was
basically something that i was missing
up until this point I really feel like
having surroundings around facades is
just as important as the facades
themselves so for example for this
building it was right on top of that
water so that really wasn't anything to
it it was just water and then straight
out facade and it just didn't look good
that way like I wanna at least add
something around it some simple foliage
just a couple of paths but not that much
but just something around it so it isn't
just a facade that stands on its own it
I do kind of want it to go along with
its surrounding so that's why I figured
the only real solution to that would be
to add a small part to it which wouldn't
really have any news but just decorate
the entire area but I'm talking about
that's why it hasn't even happened yet
so that's also amazing I suppose just
the back side isn't really too
spectacular when it comes to this
building its religious the back side for
the purpose of being able to get the
queue in there being able to get some
gates in there for the station but not
really much more and yeah that's
basically that I think this is actually
the point where I start building a
building over there I might not have oh
right this was actually the point of the
pike where you can kind of see that I
wasn't really too prepared when it comes
to this area and just kind of went all
over the place and tried all kinds of
different things and wasn't really too
focused on any particular thing which as
you can see is not really the best thing
to be in Monaco second three it just
really ends up being a tiny bit messy
and not only is it a bad way to work
in general since you did to take so much
more time trying to figure out things in
roller coaster q3 if you don't have a
set up plan beforehand it very often
also just results in just mad parks I
mean you can still make it look good if
you just have a small idea of what you
kind of want to do if you just build
things and then figure this is not
entirely amazing them remove it and
build something else and if that is good
just keep it but if that looks bad just
remove that as well and build something
else does the kind of trial and error
way of building it something rather than
having a plan beforehand but I really
just feel like if you have a plan and
this goes for buildings its goes through
park planning and parts as well if you
have a plan before end of what you kind
of want to do then it's always the best
way to just go with it and the plant
doesn't mean you need to have complete
sketches of what you're going to make
just something kind of in your head of
what your kind of want what you're kind
of going for this also goes for a
combining custom scenery by the way I
see so many people complaining you know
hey what's going on I see all these
people are using custom scenery in ways
that I can't and they're mixing up
custom scenery sets and using pieces
that I don't know we're using pieces for
different themes and I can never come up
with that and the issue with that is you
shouldn't use custom scenery for what
it's meant for per se but you also
shouldn't force yourself to use custom
scenery sets in a different way than
what they're supposed to used for
because most of the times that you'll
see somebody used for example the
chimneys from alpine village to make
pillows it isn't probably because they
figured I want to have some pillars and
I don't want to use the standard pillars
that everybody uses so I'm gonna go into
loads of different sites and see if
there's anything in there that i can use
so that i'm unique and original but
usually it's just you have a certain
plan in your head like I want to get
some square pillars over here that have
a forced perspective and it just turns
out that the chimneys from alpine
village are the best for that kind of
thing so really just have a plan just
small kind of vague plan is all right
before you do anything and just
everything will go much much better in
roller coaster
three that being said I still don't have
a plan for the backside of this station
so you'll probably see me
procrastinating that quite a bit
honestly especially that Q since I
really still don't even feel too
confident about that though this is
going to sound like I'm justifying my
own decisions right here I just feel
like if there's something in the park
that you feel insecure about doing just
procrastinate just do it later on you
shouldn't really worry about that too
much I know it's not the amazing and a
really great thing to do to decide to do
something later on at the risk of you
know just never doing that in the end
but in bali costa can three i just feel
like it's the best to do something
whenever you also kind of feel like it I
suppose I need to talk about I don't
have to do that am I finally going to
build that building on the corner right
here like I see my past self just I'm
doing all kinds of stuff over there but
it's it's still not happening all right
actually this is the point what I
realized that for some reason that
youtube converter just added this video
twice for some reason that that does
explain why the 50 who is twice as long
damn it oh well I've been talking about
food I've been talking over footage that
I've already shown never mind that's
I'll just take the original footage and
just kind of make it slower I mean it
there's no way that this video can be
even more terrible than it already is so
that'll be the episode then thank you
guys so much for watching this low
quality throwback video and I'll see you
all next time when the video is actually
going to be good and in higher quality
and not with random Orange Caramel
breaks in between so see you then